I gotta tell you when I told people to
not buy gold because gold sucks as an
investment I stirred up a hornet's nest
because you people that worship the gold
bar they think that the gold bar is the
answer to all of your financial trouble
you are some passionate goobers I'll
just tell you and you have you know
unrelentingly beat on me for the last
five years well I've been telling people
not to invest and go now I never once
said that gold was going to go to zero
or that gold was going to completely
fail I just said there's a dumb place to
put money because there's no track
record on the thing that that shows that
gold is going to be a good place
long-term to invest now if you want to
put money in gold you can put money in
gold I think it's dumb I don't have any
money in gold and of course it's it's
course-corrected now and it's gone way
down in the last year and I've gloated a
little bit about that but not much
because my goal is not for you to lose
money I don't want you to lose I just
don't want you to fall for stuff like
that and you know then there's stuff
like that is complete scam like the
Iraqi dinars scam that's going on and
people putting their money in the diner
got tweeted this morning he said what do
I do with my family they put so much
money in the Iraqi diner that they lost
their home because it didn't pay off of
course it didn't pay off you're
investing in a currency of a country
that is war-torn currency is only as
good as someone else's willingness to
accept that item in exchange and so if
if we decided carpet thread was the
medium of exchange we'd all be carrying
around a pocket full of carpet thread in
our case in America we use green pieces
of paper with president's faces on them
they have no value except to the extent
that someone else will receive them as
value what stabilizes that currency well
some government regulation stabilizes
the currency but it has been widely
accepted for generations as a medium of
exchange was so has gold yes gold has
it's been widely accepted as a medium of
exchange we all go into Walmart with
gold bars that happens all the time
it's a moronic statement of course you
don't
and if
economy fails we get we resort to go no
we don't know recovering economy has
resorted to gold since the Roman Empire
there's no historic evidence of that
crap and the so people walk around like
gold has got intrinsic value gold is
only got value to the extent someone
else will change you with you for
something else and that's what we call
money it's what we call currency when
someone else whether it's carpet thread
or paper or gold bars when you can
exchange it with someone else because
someone else trusts see there's the
essence to money it's based on trust and
currency or the currencies are only a
stable as trust and so now I got a whole
nother group of goobers after me and
that's these Bitcoin boobs but now these
are web geeks and so they're all alive
on social media and gone bananas and so
like I'm the enemy of the world cuz
don't you like the free market you'd
like Bitcoin I you know I hope it works
it may work I don't think it's going to
and it looks like it's failing as we
speak but it may work in ten years it
may have stabilized in the meantime I'm
gonna tell eight million people every
day that bitcoin is bit con and it's the
equivalent of the iraqi dinar of the web
and i'm gonna keep saying it because i'm
not putting money in it personally
because it's an unstable currency that
is regulated by no one and has no track
record and there's not even a physical
item at least with carpet thread you'd
have something in your pocket
it's bits and they can't even freaking
keep up with the bits and so one of the
major exchanges has now gone into
bankruptcy so this is not a hard concept
and it's not a lie it's not due to my
lack of knowledge of the internet I have
my lack of knowledge of the Internet is
vast I have I'm so ignorant about the
Internet it's unbelievable I am NOT
ignorant of how currency works as a
matter of fact I'm a frickin expert on
how currency works economics and finance
are the thing I've devoted
my life to studying and so I'm far from
ignorant on what Bitcoin really is at
its core it is only as good as someone
else's willingness to accept it in
exchange and for the people fooling with
it being able to keep up with it if you
walk around and you lose thousands of
dollars pieces of green paper out of
your pocket and you can't keep up with
your money then you're going to lose
money and they're to lose they can't
find them
they've been shyster and you've been
shyster but you guys think it's cool and
it's cutting edge all because it's
technology-based and I'm some kind of
freaking ignoramus and here's where your
breakdown is it's not technology based
it's trust based and it happens to
function in one of the areas where Trust
is most lacking and that's in technology
do you trust anything on the web people
now you're gonna bet money that's
web-based it's gonna be a while for this
works guys if it ever works because it's
trust based money at its core is trust
and it's spiritual and whether it's
carpet thread gold bars green pieces of
paper red pieces of paper or bits in
your computer money is trust based
Bitcoin does not have trust by anyone
except some people who are so technology
driven in their lives that they honestly
want it to work so badly that they're
blind as to how this thing is going down
so here's the deal I'm not gonna stop so
you little tech babies just keep it
rolling baby just crank it out just
crank out the Dave hate bring it on cuz
you're wrong
I am NOT trying to shut down Bitcoin I'm
talking to people who work for a living
make money and I'm asking them to not
lose their money by investing in the
iraqi dinar
of the web the bit Khan don't put your
money and stuff that is unstable put
your money in simple things that have
proven track records of decade upon
decade upon decade and then you'll have
some money when the Sun Goes Down and
when the Sun comes up I put my money in
good growth stock mutual funds I don't
put my money in single stocks too much
risk and I put my money in real estate
that's what I'm gonna tell you to do
don't put your money in there rocky Dyne
are don't put it in gold bars and don't
put it in bit cons this is the Dave
Ramsey show
you